hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the jump scare simulator
I'm assuming by the lovely HD graphics
that I have in front of me that this
game is gonna be a wonderful experience
full of clever crafting of scares and
horror the likes of which we've never
seen before
so I can't wait neither can you so let's
get into it oh god oh hello
yeah I I don't know why I found this
this game is three years old I just
looked up scary games on gamejolt for
old times sake and I found this one I I
don't know what I was expecting
no one had reviewed the game and I just
thought I'd give it a go and see what
the old what for is okay did a button or
something I'm supposed to do about this
oh stop stop don't do that don't do that
at all
Frick damn it Slendy poo well you're not
even gonna go away you're not even gonna
kill me when I'm staring at you okay
fine then I don't know expecting Oh
Frick Oh God
this is such Garbo it's such
unadulterated Garbo I wish my mouse
wasn't so sensitive in this fun that's
what I'd call this game fun well you got
me good I will admit you got me a few
times yeah good old good a good on you
game you sure did show up a storm on how
to make games good who was that and why
whet their scream cut off so abruptly
you know it's not fun if it's the same
noise over and over again can I go
through the door didn't get in whoa I'm
outside now ah wonderful hey good at
least I can play this oh the thing is
like when I download this game wait I
knew exactly what I was getting into
I knew exactly what it's getting to do
and frankly I changed my opinion on the
matter this this game is wonderful this
game is the best and the developer like
I'm sorry I didn't play this three years
ago cuz I can't imagine coinies like I
can't imagine my life without this game
at this point
like can you can you guys imagine your
life without this game at this point in
this endeavor in this weird empty field
where I don't know where I'm supposed to
go can you guys imagine that just
imagine I think this is the low res
version Resident Evil 7 oh I know it's a
remake before the remake was actually
made there's a second floor and yeah
this seems like the right still oh well
I'm up okay I'm downstairs again thought
I was up then I'm down I'm yes then I'm
no I'm hot then I'm cold
oh no I'm I'm stuck now I'm in hell
now this is hell this is hell I'm in
hell yeah I'm gonna get back I got stuck
a bit I'm gonna play the game again then
I'm gonna have to go through all the
scares again Oh Oh go Oh doh this time
I'm ready cool we're good
I don't remember where the rest of
goddammit I've already been through you
oh good this again open the door [ __ ]
that's so loud oh yeah okay I'm back I
don't know if that was worth it I really
don't god that was actually no I'm gonna
go ahead and say that wasn't worth it
not at all
hello they jump scares yeah I can't jump
off the map okay well I did that now
I think the game's over okay I guess
that's enough for now so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this little adventure into what
game development was like three years
ago
and a you know to be perfectly honest I
got a smile on my face so I'd say I had
a good time so thank you everybody so
much for watching and thanks for
watching this short video I've got more
stuff coming soon my schedules been so
wonky because I've been working on
something really special that I think
you guys are gonna like I'm not even
talking about the big project which is
something special that I know you're
gonna like but there's something that
I've been working very hard on myself
and can't wait to show you so thanks
again and as always in the next video
[Music]